many point-blank misses we had at the  rim how many uh  fast breaks that we blew uh in  transition where we didn't get anything  out of and they got something  um but the last part of that we just did  not trust  each other we didn't trust the open guy  tonight  doc you think ben simmons can still be a  point guard  for a championship team like the one you  guys want to become yeah david i don't  know that question or the answer to that  right now  um you know so i don't know the answer  to that  what do you uh when you say get in the  gym with him  what uh what needs to be done i mean  obviously this is this is frustrating  yeah i mean i that's that's between ben  and i  thank you  doc was there was there anything you  could have done to give kevin eric to  give seth a little more help on